come to our field of dreams
and play ball
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we've kept our promise major league
baseball has kept its promise
the dream is still alive
there's probably just one question to
answer
is this heaven
[Music]
i don't think i heard you is this heaven
[Applause]
yes it is
well that guy will lance lynn who has
been sensational
in his first year with the white sox
leading major league baseball with an
era
just over two
he's been unreal
2-2 is in for strength three one away
how about that a strikeout on high
heated 94 and back-to-back strikeouts
two out here in the first inning for new
york left-hander is andrew heaney
30-year-old lefty 6-2 200 pounds from
oklahoma city and here's jose with two
outs here's the o2 pitch
that is shot into left field back at the
wall it is gone
and the first home run in mlb history in
iowa belongs to jose abreu
a laser over the wall and left in the
white sox lead one to nothing here in
the first
strong strong man always an rbi machine
the last three four years
three-two pitch
is
called strike three third will be out in
the dugouts that the home plate umpire
pat holberg's giving the high strike
another strikeout on the list that's
four in the game already for lance lynn
bonkat awaits and now out in front of
that pitch strikes out second strikeout
for hiney ten and a half game lead in
the division
good pitch by hiney and out number two
here in the second look at that
that is a drone circling a hot air
balloon over corn next to a big league
game in iowa the drone to that balloon
looks like a fly to us
one two pitch is ripped into right
base it that will send lemay hue to
second that's it it's two on two out a
walk a single with aaron judge coming up
you look at those special kicks he's got
going for the field of dreams big aaron
judge steps up
looking to do damage here
one-two pitch that is smoked into right
and into the corn
aaron judge puts the yankees on top with
a three-run shot here in the third
try to sneak another piece of
cheese
past
aaron judge and he's another guy that
can make
a ball look like he's a left-handed
hitter
to right field
all of this with two outs
maybe it's the shoes got to be the shoes
a really pure game in the middle of iowa
with uh
in the middle of a cornfield it's it's
kind of surreal to be honest here's a
shot down the left field line by
anderson
lead runner engels going to dig for
third and now they bring him around as
mcewing waves him home and it's an rbi
double to make it a one-run game
anderson delivers with a shot down the
left-field line and engel who drew that
lead off walk comes around to score he's
really good down and in and down in the
zone and this season since being
activated from the injured list on july
25th five homers 14 rbis two on two out
and here's one down the right field line
at the wall it is gone
and right on cue jimenez goes the
opposite way
a three-run shot and the white sox are
back on top
the hottest hitter in the major leagues
right now
has just made it five to three chicago
well he likes to get extended and they
were trying to go in with a fastball and
didn't get it in and this is what you
can do when you're strong
and this is what happens when you miss
your pitch five runs on four hits for
the white sox here's zavala flying one
into right back at the wall it is gone
wow this stadium is working perfectly
two run shot into right
if you're a hitter
and it's seven to three white sox here
in the fourth
i'm starting to get the sense john that
this ball carries well out to right yeah
i watched vp and if it was a normal bp i
would stop watching it because the ball
was jumping right so jordan digs back in
he has struck out and single
here's one down the line off the bat of
gardner it is gone
brett gardner has made this a three run
ball game as the corn out in right
gobbling up some baseballs here tonight
a rocket
and for gardner home run number five on
the year and for the yankees they're
hoping that gardner can get gold
the flame thrower kopeck takes over and
uh wow yeah he can throw up to 100 miles
an hour but luke voight waits and takes
it right down the chute struck him out
at 100 miles per hour and now would be
a tougher issue
a swing and a miss struck him out and
kopeck does the job here in the sixth
bases are loaded
and a big moment
one of the newer yankees joey gallo
coming up
ground ball up the middle and bobbled
but the out as tim anderson makes the
play
and gallow bounces into the force out
now that your x number of innings
after eating that one oh you want
another one yeah i want another one to
know you're feeling good one two pitch
swing and a miss foul tip hung on to by
the catcher zavala
two down ten years later he's the white
sox manager where it all began for him
in 1979 2-2 pitch a swing and a miss
and that ends the inning
and hendricks will get to deal with
aaron judge the spot where judge the
best he can do is make it a one-run game
finn and puffin with a count two and one
on aaron judge
high fly ball
this ball is way out of here
one run game
second of the night 25
for the year for big number 99
watch out if he gets hot
a judgy and blast to be sure
all rise here comes the judge
and another monstrous shot into that
cornfield
wow that was a shot goodness
there is giancarlo
gallo at first the tying run stanton the
go ahead run
[Applause]
yankees on top
8-7
what a comeback
judge a three-run home run stanton a
two-run home run it is a stantonian
blast
giancarlo
no sleep won't stop
hey it's a two-run home run and the
yankees
dead in the water now have an 8-7 lead
and dead in the water two outs two
strikeouts and you know two out hits win
your ball games
what a comeback for this team the tying
run is on tim anderson digging in one
for four tonight good matchup here for a
low ball hitter sinking
fastball
anderson
hits it in the end right back at the
wall and the white sox win it
well you can throw the party but you
never know how it's gonna turn out
that's unreal and how about six runs on
the board in the ninth inning alone and
the white sox with a walk-off 9-8 win
this was some
kind of night for baseball it sure was
and the most energetic guy on the team
ends up winning it
and letting everybody know about as soon
as he made contact he knew it was gone
and a
what a game
makes a winner out of hendricks a loser
out of
britain now this just was a good match
up for
the way that
tim anderson likes to hit and he gets
the barrel to bat down to the ball in
the low part of the zone about as good
as anybody and